House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
making good on his threat,
booting Democrats
Adam Schiff and Eric
Swalwell off the House
Intelligence Committee.
The speaker tweeting
he rejected their appointments
because he is, quote,
committed to returning the commi
to one genuine,
one of genuine honesty and credi
Lauren Fox
joins us live from Capitol Hill.
It's it's so important to fact c
the reasoning that McCarthy has
for booting the two of them.
Lauren
McCarthy has been warning
that this was the decision
he was going to make for months
and years now.
Ever since Democrats
voted on the House floor
to reject two members
from their committees
to kick them off committees.
Both Paul
Gosar
and Marjorie Taylor
Greene for making threatening co
at the time
against their sitting colleagues
That was something that House Sp
Nancy Pelosi said really warrant
from House Democrats.
Kevin McCarthy said this last ni
about his reasoning
for kicking Schiff
and Swalwell asked the Intel Com
This is not
anything political.
This is not similar
to what the Democrats did.
But integrity matters
and they have failed in that pla
From Adam Schiff,
using a position of the intel
chair, lying
to the American public again and
But McCarthy has been warning
for months now that this was the
he was going to take.
He's been saying that Democrats
made their bed years ago
when they made the decision
to kick off Republicans from com
So it's really interesting
that he said this has nothing to
what Democrats have done in the
It's interesting
that I'm wondering, though,
this is probably just the beginn
if McCarthy is going to make oth
like this.
Well, all eyes are on whether or
he tries
to bring to the floor
a vote
to oust Ilhan Omar
from her committee assignment, a
who serves on foreign affairs.
Here's one of the issues with th
The Select Committee on Intellig
He has unilateral power,
but he would need a vote
of the full House.
And there are some signs
that a lot of Republican rank an
may not be comfortable ousting O
from her seat on that committee.
Kevin McCarthy keeping a promise
and wielding his new power as sp
removing Congressman Adam
Schiff and Eric Swalwell,
both Democrats
from the Intelligence Committee.
Those California Democrats
just moments ago calling it an
act of political vengeance.
This isn't
about any
individual committee assignment.
This is about an institution whe
the speaker of the House
is using his power
to go after his political oppone
He is continuing this destructiv
set by his party
leader of tearing down our insti
The speaker insists that's not t
He says this has everything
to do with honesty and credibili
The one thing I will always do,
I'll put the national security
ahead of partizan politics any d
I don't care
if they're in my party or not.
Integrity matters
with me in studio
to share their reporting
and their insights.
CNN's Casey Hunt, CNN's M.J.
Lee and Ron
Colvin of The Washington Post.
You saw in the photos there,
Congressman Swalwell and Schiff.
You heard from Ilhan
Omar, the Democrat from Minnesot
Also there, she's next.
McCarthy says he can't.
He can
because the intelligence
is select committee.
He has the power of speaker
to remove Swalwell and Schiff.
Omar's next.
The full House has to vote on th
The Democrats say this is retrib
especially for the two Intellige
Committee Democrats
because they stood up to Donald
Is that all it is?
That's what it looks like right
It looks like it is a political
Of course,
this is something that McCarthy
promise that he would remove the
from intelligence.
Of course,
giving background to the situati
Both were involved
in the impeachment efforts by De
both impeachments of Trump.
And both are saying that
this is what this is about.
Now, with Ilhan Omar,
the representative from Minnesot
that's a little different.
That does have to go through a H
vote situation.
The question
now is, does
McCarthy have those votes
from Republicans?
There are a handful of Republica
who are saying they're not comfo
voting on that
to kick her off of that committe
There's also one Republican who
he is in Florida right now
going through,
I guess, rehabilitation from an
And he may not be on the House
floor to vote.
So there is a question right now
of if that will be successful.
But, of course, it's
it's just a lot of politics.
There are the specifics.
There's a lot of politics.
That's an understatement to that
There are the specifics
of what the Republicans
air their grievances
against these members.
But is it really about that
or is it about
you know,
this is
this is to prove
that there's a new sheriff in to
I mean,
I think it's
fundamentally about politics bef
it's about anything else, John.
I do think this shows you
why norms are important in our s
because, you know,
the reality is Democrats
started down this road
by removing a couple of Republic
or removing Marjorie Taylor Gree
from her committee assignments.
Now, that they will say
is totally different
because it was related to death
against other members of the Hou
Right.
So in that case,
they say the details matter,
but the reality is they did it,
which is why
this is now on the table now.
There are some differences betwe
you know, Republicans and
frankly, I've talked to some Dem
who behind the scenes
will talk about issues
with Eric Swalwell
and ties
to a Chinese national
that they say raised questions a
and an intern
who worked for him,
that he says he did the right th
He says once the FBI came to him
he said, what do you need and co
But the Republicans continue to
But there's nothing like that
for Adam Schiff.
Right, who has really become
public enemy number one
from a political perspective
for many of these Republicans.
I mean, it is hard to overstate
how much they can't
stand Adam Schiff behind the sce
for strictly political reasons.
So, you know,
I do think there are differences
among the cases,
but the reality is here, like
we're in this place because of h
our politics are.
And it's a new place.
It's not a place
that Congress used to go in the
And I think it's worth discussin
whether that's good for the coun
I think
McCarthy will continue to try to
that all he's doing
is going
by the precedent set by Democrat
in the last Congress.
But there is a very clear distin
between removing members
from a committee
or refusing
to allow them to sit on a commit
because you have some
political or ideological differe
objections that have to do with
and ideology versus
doing this
because somebody has a real ethi
or character issue.
Like I think
just being very clear
about the two distinctions
there is really, really importan
And so the next challenge
will be on the floor, as you kno
to remove Ilhan Omar
from the Foreign Affairs Committ
you have to have a vote
of the full House.
She says this
Unless McCarthy can say how.
Myself, Adam Schiff and Eric
Swalwell are a danger to the ins
and our colleagues.
And he's not following the examp
that set by Speaker Pelosi.
That's to your point.
Paul Gosar, for example, was str
from his committees
after he posted his staff did it
but he posted with his authority
a video of the anime
anime video essentially
where he's fantasizing about kil
another member of Congress.
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
the question
there is
a number of Republicans
have raised reservations about O
particularly who very well-liked
even by Republican colleagues.
They think she's liberal and all
She she has given
a bunch of anti-Semitic statemen
And Don Bacon,
one of the Republicans
who said he had reservations abo
came out of the conference meeti
saying he would vote to remove h
because they read in the confere
meeting a number
of very anti-Semitic statements
She has apologized in the past,
but apparently not enough,
apparently not enough
for some Republicans.
And they sort of are going back
with how they're going to determ
what they'll do in her situation
because we have heard
from moderate
Republicans who are saying, no,
I think this is going a step
too far with her that she did
give an apology early on
and this was actually a few year
But I just think it's a part
of the congressional role
just keeping things going
keeping one side,
getting a point over the other s
They have their new and we'll wa
play out.
We'll talk about
this more in detail later.
But they also have a new panel
to investigate COVID origins
that has Marjorie
Taylor Greene
anti-vaxxer, who has said some t
that flunk every fact check Jewi
school lasers.
Yes, Jewish space claims. Right.
And Dr.
Ronny Jackson
Trump's former physician
at the White House,
is now a congressman from Texas
who has also
said some things that would not
through medical school about COV
But we'll watch this play out